hay bastante expectativa aquí estaban
esperando desde la madrugada que sonaran
esas alarmas que sonaron alrededor del
mediodía Y antes como en la mañana al
final de la mañana y pues hubo bastante
susto sin embargo la vida sigue normal
las calles están llenas hay tráfico en
en las calles de kiev y todos nos dicen
que bueno que que no hay otra opción que
seguir la vida a pesar de de Ese temor
porque todo el mundo cuando te dice te
dice cruzan los dedos saben que hoy y
mañana pueden ser los días más difíciles
esperando que el presidente Vladimir
Putin vaya a lanzar nuevos ataques para
recordar aquel la invasión a full escala
que comenzó el 24 de febrero el año
pasado y que ha sido fallida recordemos
que su principal objetivo era venir y
uno de los grandes ejemplos de ese
fracaso es que hoy está aquí como usted
decía el presidente
del gobierno español Pedro Sánchez que
además ellos van a tener la presidencia
del Consejo europeo a partir de julio y
ha dicho que uno de sus objetivos es
tratar de sacar que esta guerra se acabe
antes de que se acabe este año Así que
es uno de los objetivos También estuvo
el presidente Joe biden esta semana Así
que esto es dado moral a la población de
quiebra la espera como decía de lo que
puedas pasar en las próximas horas y en
el y mañana especialmente